my name is Isabella canto Laney and I'm
12 years old sixth grade at red rocks
elementary and my family I have my mom
my dad my dad's my coach he has been for
three long years and he and I have
worked really well together and I have
two little brothers and a little sister
who's in fourth grade my little brothers
are increase cool and second grade
they're really great they're my biggest
supporters they were praying for me the
whole time they love me so much it's
awesome and then I have a dog named
drusy she's so cute little mutt
um you should probably visit red rocks
park which is the park that I'm standing
in front of here because it's really
beautiful I think you should become a
national park my school is stationed
right in front of it and you can see the
park out the back window it is really
cool and there's also some other nice
places bouldering golden hour nice
tourist areas and there's bear creek
lake state park down the road and the
people here are really friendly and nice
I would probably travel to the Baltic
States area like Copenhagen Norway
Denmark Sweden Finland and Estonia
because that area has always intrigued
me and there's so many there's so much
good history there good museums and
things to see like that I just really
want to go there
we write a lot of our stuff down in
notebooks so far we filled up four of
them and we also my dad reviews
everything with me and we look up stuff
online and we make flashcards I would
just fish out of a little basket review
from time to time
w national park is along a meander on
what river in western Africa it's the
Niger River and it's on burkina faso
niger and benin
you
oh I just want to thank my school
because they've supported me a lot all
my classmates made big posters for me
and thanks for to mr. Harrod for filming
this video and my principal miss ham
mrs. Hamilton and my teacher and thanks
and my dad of course he's my coach
you